all right Kaylee mcinerney
great job thank you
and thank you and hello New York how are
you
welcome to Hannity
we got a rowdy rowdy crowd tonight the
live studio audience tonight somewhere
in America
Hunter Biden is celebrating Christmas
come early for the reform crackhead uh
he will not spend a single day in jail
not one day can you believe it after
after striking that sweetheart deal with
his daddy's doj how convenient anyway
meanwhile Hunter's child support
payments remember the little girl in
Arkansas innocent four-year-old little
girl uh that he and Joe and Jill Biden
have completely abandoned well anyway
the child care payments were reduced
they reported 75 percent uh and the girl
does not get to take her dad's name
which might be a blessing in disguise uh
so congrats to the bidens we know that
they're probably Overjoyed tonight but
one day Joe and Jill Biden's
granddaughter will know that her
grandfather was the president of the
United States and completely abandoned
and disowned her we'll get to that and
coming up we're going to hear from the
attorney representing rapper Kodak Black
who was sentenced to more than three
years in prison he was charged with the
same Federal weapons crime as zero
experience Hunter Biden 46 months in
jail he also by the way will hear from
John Solomon he has exclusive new
details from the IRS whistleblower who
accused the feds of giving Hunter
preferential treatment but first tonight
we begin with the Blockbuster testimony
of special counsel John Durham way too
late and too few indictments but anyway
it was on Capitol Hill today delivering
some much needed truth to the tin foil
hat liars and collusion truthers that
never happened in the Democratic party
and of course their willing accomplices
in the media mob they were the ones
peddling lies to you in this country for
three years and some of them even
getting pollen surprises as a result now
first up is the congenital liar himself
Adam Schiff now this was interesting
today he couldn't believe that a foreign
government would actually call up an
American citizen and offer dirt on a
political opponent and and I'm like
really Adam because Adam Schiff is the
only one in America that actually talked
to somebody that he believed to be a
Russian it was a Russian prankster uh
and uh guess what what uh we got the
tape listen
Don Jr was informed that a Russian
official was offering the Trump campaign
quote very high level and sensitive
information unquote that would be
incriminating if Hillary Clinton was
part of quote Russia and its government
support of Mr Trump you aware of that
sure people get phone calls all the time
from individuals who claim to have
information like that really the son of
a presidential candidate gets calls all
the time from before in government
offering dirt on their important
opponent is that what you're saying I
don't think this is unique in your
experience she met with Trump and she
brought him one hour Russian girl
celebrity all gabuzova who also known as
a person with a strange reputation Olga
and how do you spell her name Olga
busaba and what's the nature of the
compromat
well there were pictures of naked Trump
you said that it's not uncommon to get
offers of help from a hostile foreign
government a presidential campaign
directed at the president's son you
really stand by that Mr Durham saying
that it that people could make phone
calls
um making uh claims all the time that
you may have experienced and so Putin
was made aware uh of the availability of
the compromising material yes of course
thank you very much we will be back in
touch uh with you through our staff to
make arrangements uh to obtain these
materials for our committee and and for
the FBI and and I appreciate you
reaching out to us let me explain that
was Adam Schiff being pranked by
somebody he believes to be a Russian
telling him and giving him compromising
my videos on Donald Trump what was the
nature of the compromising materials uh
pictures of naked tanam you have
pictures of naked Trump does Vladimir
know but of course Vladimir see the
picture
you know
Adam Schiff no shame as it turns out the
collusion was coming from inside the
House of Representatives it was shift
that was colluding with the Russians
digging up dirt on a presidential
candidate compromising materials on
Donald Trump
but tonight the good news is Adam Schiff
has been formally censored by the House
of Representatives and Democrats
they're not too happy let's take a look
the A's are 213 and the Nays are 209
with six answering present the
resolution adopted without objection the
motion it consider is the related on the
table
house will be in order
maybe Adam Schiff should stop getting
compromised in materials anyway he's a
Serial liar congenital liar conspiracy
theorist he lied to this country for
three long years rightly censored on the
house floor and yet here we are in year
eight of the never-ending Trump Russia
collusion hoax and a far-fetched
conspiracy theory bought and paid for by
Hillary Rodham Clinton propagated by our
federal government not one thing in her
dirty disinformation was in Russian
dossier was ever proven true no real
evidence a collusion of conspiracy and
in the words of Durham operation
Crossfire hurricane never ever should
have been opened take a look
Mr Durham did you see evidence of
collusion between Russia and the Trump
campaign in 2016. no
so the American public that has been
told this hoax for years it was just
that a hoax is that correct
our investigation showed that there were
a lot of failures in the FBI and how
they did this investigation that did not
disclose or reveal information or
evidence concerning any conspiracy or
conclusion between Mr Trump and Russian
authorities
okay then why did the FBI spend years on
a hoax two words pure political that's
three words political bias they hated
Donald Trump were desperate to take him
down take a look
I've had any number of FBI agents who
I've worked with over the years some of
them are tired some are still in place
who have come to me and apologized for
the banner in which that investigation
was undertaken I take that seriously
there are investigative activities
undertaken or not undertaken here which
raised real concerns about whether or
not the law was Fallen to policies in
place the FBI were followed there are
some individuals who clearly expressed a
personal bias
anti-trump zealots at the FBI and the
Washington field office was so desperate
to get Donald Trump that they frauded a
fisa court when not one single item on
that fisa application regarding the
dossier was true or corroborated not one
James Comey signed three of them uh talk
about a higher honor Comey really and
that was used then to ruin Carter Page's
life get into the Trump campaign
transition team in the Trump White House
take a look
several of the relevant fisa
applications at issue in the crossfire
investigation omitted references to what
was clearly relevant and highly
exculpatory information that should have
been disclosed to the fisa court
multiple FBI Personnel who signed or
assisted in preparing renewal
applications for that same fisa Warren
acknowledged that they did not believe
that the target Mr Page was a threat to
National Security much less a knowing
agent of a formed power which is what
the law requires
it appears from our investigation that
the FBI leadership dismissed those
concerns turns out Carter page was
innocent and actually worked for a
three-letter agency and ended up being a
patriot that often went to dangerous
places and shared that Intel with our
own government now despite the abuse the
bias the corruption the misconduct there
have been that has been very few real
consequences they got away with their
lives they got away with lying to advise
a court four times virtually no reform
no accountability not even an apology
from the mob the media not even a
correction not even an I'm sorry not
even a here's your surprise back it's
way past time for a recording at your
FBI they've been politicized they've
been weaponized Christopher Ray needs to
go the FBI is hyper partisan far left
Washington field office must be
dismantled the entire Bureau which used
to be the premier law enforcement agency
in the world has got to be rehabilitated
top to bottom or we will no longer have
equal justice or application in our laws
under this country and that means our
constitution is meaningless that means
the FBI under both Comey and Ray has
sadly been weaponized and politicized
just like the Department of Justice and
since 2015 the bureau threw cinderblocks
on the scales of not one but two
presidential elections they push the
Russia hoax they pre-bunked the very
true Hunter Biden laptop story that they
had since December of 2019 and now
they're obstructing chairman Comer's
investigation into Biden's alleged
bribery scheme they want they want to
offer no assistance and oddly enough
they still don't even seem interested in
the contents of Hunter's laptop look at
this Hunter's very nervous looking
attorney not the good one Abby Lowell
who's a serious lawyer who really did a
good job on behalf of the Biden family
but the other lawyer said said Federal
investigators never even brought up the
contents and their five-year
investigation into Hunter of Hunter's
laptop for those years they had the
laptop take a look
do you have any idea of
um Hunter Biden's laptop had anything to
do with this investigation was it used I
don't no I don't I mean have you ever
asked about it
um
I can't recall being asked about it to
be honest with you Republicans will say
the laptop has has tons of proof that
there was that Hunter Biden participated
in corruption that there's Financial
proof that President Biden and Hunter
Biden were connected and in the gains
that were made overseas by by Hunter
Biden have you ever seen any proof of
that no I know I haven't seen anybody
make a actual persuasive case that
something was done
and you know you asked whether or not
the subject to the laptop was was part
of the investigation it's been out there
and you know we don't have any
proof of it that there was any kind of
violation excuse me think about it
Hunter's laptop it has material evidence
prostitution drug use gun crimes tax
crimes financial information about all
of Hunter's foreign lobbying did he
register as a under the Fair Act I doubt
it and sketchy foreign business deals
how much money was he making from China
Russia Kazakhstan Ukraine and a dozen
other countries what about the profit
sharing with the big guy or giving half
of his income to Pops meaning Joey Biden
your president and zero interest the FBI
has been in the possession of that
laptop since December 2019. according to
John Solomon he'll join us later they
verified the authenticity of that laptop
in the spring of 2020 but Federal
investigators never asked about it they
never brought it up with hunter or his
attorney talk about a weaponized FBI and
doj protecting the Biden Syndicate it is
not a serious investigation was never a
serious investigation and this is an
effort to convince you that they have
that appearance of fairness all while
protecting Joe Biden and his depraved
family and clearly at this point with
very few exceptions the federal
bureaucracy is little more than an
extension of the democratic party
comprised of Democrats working to elect
and protect Democrats while targeting
conservatives and anyone with the last
name Trump or anyone associated with the
last name Trump and Congress and our
next Republican president better clean
house in a huge way without delay or
this politicized weaponized federal
government will spiral out of control
even further they are now more
emboldened than ever because they've
never been held accountable hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else